Face au défi climatique,
environnementaux et sociaux,
moi je veux être 1 caillou
dans la chaussure des impérialistes,
capitalistes et milliardaires
qui profèrent, qui profitent,
qui profitent de leurs
positions dominantes en usant notre planète
afin d'en faire des profits scandaleux.
À l'heure où la
Commission européenne
décide de faire circuler des camions
de 60t sur nos routes,
je souhaite au contraire
avec Léon que le transport ferroviaire de marchandise
reprenne la place qu'il a perdu depuis les années 90.
Je souhaite que les transports soient utilisés à défunt
écologique pour le bien du du plus grand nombre.
Nous voulons avec Léon
que les transports soient au service de la population,
au service des territoires.